I got job security people are not going
to stop walking down that aisle they are
not going to stop having kids with
people that they probably should have
thought through whether they would have
kids with that person or not but I'm
glad they are I'm glad they're taking
that leap I'm glad they're taking that
risk it's this whole Beautiful Mess that
we're all a part of it's like taking
that risk taking that leap of
vulnerabilities with what this whole
thing is about man what a danger if we
didn't you know like like every
you know you you you hear about people
like Alexander Hamilton or you hear
about you know people who like they were
born of circumstances that like
these two people should never have had a
kid
and then they did and that kid changes
the world you know and like moves the
dial forward and what I like what a
great mistake like what a great it's
that you can't ever say it's a mistake
like what an amazing thing that happened
and and I think that that's one of the
things I like about divorce as a
practice and as almost looking at it
like a spiritual practice I think you
just don't know
what is a blessing right in the world
like you just don't know like I my
father
I've spoken about this before publicly
and he does frequently my father is an
alcoholic my father's been in recovery
now for seven years I think yeah but he
was a bad alcoholic Vietnam veteran my
whole life and only got sober you know
when I was in my 40s
and a lot of the personality
characteristics I have are consistent
with those of adult children of
Alcoholics
you know desire for control and control
issues
um you know a lot a lot of those things
and I love my life like I'm having a
great time if I died tomorrow man I did
more learn more earn more loved more
than I ever dreamed
and so I'm so glad my dad was an
alcoholic
and if you said to me how do you raise
kids like I wouldn't say like well you
definitely want to be an alcoholic
because like your kids can eat a lot of
really good discipline lessons from that
experience like no like I wouldn't you
know I wouldn't want that for but but
but it's born like all these wonderful
things were born of this awful situation
so I think divorce the same thing like I
I we make these mistakes right but
they're not really you know I often have
to say to my clients when they're like
oh I wish I'd never married this person
I'm like you love your kids right
like your kids are half that person
they would not be the organism they are
without that person's DNA so you can't
regret
being with that person if you love your
kids like if you love your kids those
kids don't exist without that person and
I I don't know how we refocus on that
you know I don't know may we give anyone
going through I've actually had a theory
which I've not said out loud but I'll
say it to you because it's just us
talking
I I think
if we could figure out a way
to take a divorcing couple
that is interested in potentially
mediating
and put them in a setting
where we could give them both psilocybin
like a good dose like two and a half
three grams
and have them do individual sessions
with you know controlled setting with a
a a guide right
and and have them sort of do that in her
work and then have them do some kind of
a of a session together
after they've had that experience that's
psychedelic experience I actually think
you could do transformative divorce work
because I I have found myself and
certainly the many people that I've
talked to who've had
psilocybin experiences and in particular
but any psychedelic experience many of
the empathogens right
um
or even like MDMA you know like MDMA
which is you know is an empathogen and
if if we brought that space and the
divorce and conflict resolution space
together
that sort of
psychopharmacological intervention on
empathy one's empathy receptors or one's
connectivity I think that would could be
radically transforming it would be
logistically an absolute nightmare it
would never get done from a legal
standpoint but man like I I think
sometimes like that if because
I think the more that you can bring
people to the awareness of connection
that comes from
many people's psychedelic experiences I
think they could then extrapolate that
into
their understanding of the conflict and
disconnect they're having with their
partner so really lean into the like use
this brink of divorce as a kind of
catalyst for doing a lot of
soul-searching a lot of growth together
that was what appealed to me about it I
mean before I started doing it is it was
this idea that this is a opportunity
to for radical reinvention yeah like it
was an opportunity for people to say
okay now what like I didn't expect that
now what and it was to be part of the
architecture of that like I didn't look
at it like I'm helping demolish the
building
it was like I'm tearing down the
building so we can build the new one
which I hope is filled with joy and
abundance and peace and love and real
love real satisfaction like my my
ex-wife
is married for over a decade now to a
phenomenal guy who is perfect for her
and he's Nothing Like Me by the way like
like if you met him and you met both of
us you'd go well no one could love both
of these guys because like if you like
this flavor you wouldn't like this
flavor like I am impatient fast talking
like skip to the end we gotta Land This
Plane come on and he's like he's
therapist he's chill he's like patient
and they're perfect together and I can
say that as someone who loves her and
loved her you know and knows her or knew
her like and and I I think if we can
you know if we can radically view
honestly like without jealousy without
you know without the sense of like look
at it and just go yeah yeah okay like
this like this is the love this person
needed like that doesn't mean my love
sucks just means it wasn't the right one
for this person you know like there's
someone and there's a lid for every pot
you know like she found her lid I want
her to find her lid that's good you know
and there's billions of pots out there
and we just need to match them with the
proper lid yeah not hit each other over
the head with them all day long yeah man
this is such a romantic few hours we've
got to spend together
and there's even a candle burning is
there all this lovely all right brother
thanks so much James thank you thanks
for having me